>> Greg: WELCOME BACK, LET'S
FIND OUT IF WE DID ANYTHING
WRONG THIS WEEK.
>> WELL, GREG, HE'S ACTUALLY THE
FACT-CHECKER AT CNN.
HE'S INCREDIBLY BUSY THESE DAYS.
BUT FIRST UP, LET'S HEAR YOUR
COMMENTS FROM MONDAY ABOUT THE
BODY MASS INDEX.
DIRECTOR MIKE, LIGHTS, CAMERA,
FACTION.
>> WE'VE SHIFTED THE DEFINITION
SO THAT EVERYBODY IS OBESE.
LIKE BY DEFINITION.
>> WELL, IT LOOKS LIKE YOU ARE
PARTIALLY RIGHT.
ACCORDING TO THE NIH AND THE
CDC, THE THRESHOLD FOR BEING
CONSIDERED OVERWEIGHT WAS
LOWERED IN 1998 FROM A BMI OF
27.8 TO 25.
SO NOT EVERYONE HAS TO SAY IS
CONSIDERED OBESE, BUT THE CHANGE
BROUGHT U.S. DEFINITION IN LINE
WITH THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION AND THOSE GUYS ARE
NEVER WRONG ABOUT ANYTHING.
>> Greg: YOU HAVE A FAT FACE.
>> IT'S BEEN OUTDATED AND
OVERRATED.
WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON, GREG.
>> Greg: CAT, LET'S LISTEN TO
YOUR COMMENTS FROM MONDAY ON
POST-PANDEMIC FRIENDSHIPS.
MAGIC MIKE, HIT IT.
>> IF YOU WANT TO BE HOT, LOOK
ODD, YOU ACTUALLY NEED UGLIER
FRIENDS.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU,
THANK YOU.
FINALLY, WE COME TO IT.
>> OKAY, THIS IS TECHNICALLY
TRUE, BUT MORALLY WRONG.
>> I DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT.
>> CLEARLY NOT.
BUT IT'S ACTUALLY A COGNITIVE
BIAS KNOWN AS THE UGLY FRIEND OF
FACT AND IT'S REAL ACCORDING TO
A 2016 STUDY.
>> YEAH, NO --
>> YOU GO AHEAD.
>> IN THIS CASE YOU KIND OF DO.
ASHLEY, IF WE COULD, LET'S SHOW
A PICK OF MY FRIEND ISAAC.
WE GO CLUBBING TOGETHER ON THE
WEEKENDS.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO MOVE ON.
LET'S FINISH WHERE IT ALL BEGAN
WITH MY MAN, GREG.
GREG, LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
YOU SAID TUESDAY ABOUT TWITTER
TRENDS.
ROLL IT, MIKE.
>> Greg: HERE'S AN INTERESTING
FACT I LEARNED TODAY.
TWITTER TRENDS ARE BASED ON
REALLY SMALL NUMBERS.
ANYWHERE FROM 1200-1900 TWEETS
OVER A SIX HOUR PERIOD CAN GET A
TWITTER TRENDING.
THAT IS NOTHING.
>> WELCOME A SOCIAL MEDIA
ANALYSTS CAN ONLY GUESS HOW
TWITTER'S TRENDING ALGORITHM
WORKS BECAUSE IT ISN'T PUBLIC.
AND THIS IS FUN, I HAPPEN TO
FIND THE SHODDY MARKETING SITE
YOU GOT YOUR INFORMATION FROM.
FUN FACT, THE AUTHOR OF THAT
RESEARCH HAD HER TWITTER ACCOUNT
SUSPENDED.
THERE YOU GO, BECAUSE SHE WAS
TELLING THE TRUTH.
SHE PAID THE PRICE.
AND IN FACT, MOST TWITTER USERS
SEE TRENDS TAILORED TO THEM,
WHICH MAKES SENSE WHEN I
BORROWED YOUR PHONE YESTERDAY
AND SAW THE TOP TWEETS WERE FOR
PLATFORM SHOES.
GREG, IT LOOKS LIKE I'M BEING
TOLD I'M OUT OF TIME.
AS OF GOT TO GO, I'LL SEE Y